in episodes I, II, and III,
by the way.
- Oh, you're talking
about George Lucas
and how he's been
completely seduced
by C.G.I.
- Oh, [bleep]!
- Paint?
- This is a new shirt.
- Are you kidding me?
- Damn!
- Damn.
- Oh, God--
- That sucks.
- This is so--
look at this. [chuckles]
It's like I got
two little paint titties
on my shirt now. [chuckles]
[dubstep music]
- What are you looking at?
- Hmm?
What?
- Dude, my eyes are up here.
- Yeah.
Eyes.
- Wha--dude--
- [music stops suddenly]
- --what are you doing?
It's paint.
What are you doing?
- Come on,
we've had a good time
today, haven't we?
You know?
We hung out the whole day.
- It's paint!
Paint!
It comes off. See?
See how that comes off, huh?
- Yeah.
Yeah. Yes.
- Oh, dude, stop it.
Just stop it.
- You want me to stop it,
then stop licking
your little titties.
- They're not real titties.
- What?
- Oh--
- [groans]
- Really? Twice?
- Unbelievable.
- Hello, ladies.
[dubstep music]
Yeah.
- ♪ Crazy, crazy, does, does ♪